i just want to remind you before we go
through the details of the britton house
trial which has just gone completely
sideways for the prosecution it's a
complete fail for the prosecution and
honestly has created significant issues
for me with institutional trust i think
the last couple of years in particular
have demonstrated that all of the
institutional distrust that frankly
drove donald trump to the presidency
was well-founded it is it is deeply
disturbing when you see that
institutions that you are supposed to
trust
have been lying to you are manipulatable
are not honest they don't do their
fundamental job and when you see trials
like the written house trial
you think to yourself okay i'm not sure
how i'm supposed to trust that the
system is apolitical
and we've seen this in nearly every area
of american life we've seen
bureaucracies that are designed to
protect you at your workplace now being
used to ram down vaccine mandates on 85
million americans we've seen cdc
a
system that is supposed to prevent the
spread of disease telling homeowners
that they're not allowed to evict
renters
we we've had bureaucracies that have
been completely twisted into what they
were not supposed to be the fbi and the
doj basically using clinton oppo dump
research in order to initiate
investigations on allies of president
trump and then spend four years
essentially propping up an investigation
predicated on false
nonsense that was propagated by the
clinton team
you know we've seen so many institutions
in american life they've completely
blown all credibility
what we're now watching as the
supposedly independent federal reserve
takes its orders from the biden
administration what we're watching as
the media which was supposed to be the
arbiter of truth becomes essentially
just a democratic left-wing talking
points propaganda machine
we've watched as facebook and google and
all of our social media tech companies
the big tech companies are batted about
by the state so much that they
essentially just become propagators of
democratic party propaganda attempting
to scuttle any outlet that doesn't
mirror those positions
all of this is super disturbing for
people and the written house trial is
just one of those moments when the truth
bobs its head above the waves and you
say oh there's probably an iceberg under
there there's definitely an iceberg
under there so i just want to go for a
walk down memory lane grabian put out a
supercut of all of the various pundits
and commentators who had things to say
about kyle rittenhouse and the immediate
aftermath of what happened in kenosha
wisconsin
last year you'll recall the kenosha
wisconsin was set on fire over jacob
blake after the media promulgated a lie
which is that the police shot an unarmed
man for no good reason it was not true
about jacob blake jacob blake was a
criminal and jacob blake was carrying a
knife and the police shot jacob blake
because he refused to put down the knife
after they ordered him a million times
to put down the knife and all of it was
on tape and the media ran with the false
narrative anyway and kenosha burned and
then kyle rittenhouse
who apparently knew the the people who
were attempting to guard a car
dealership decided that he was going to
go 20 minutes down the road and he was
going to help protect the car dealership
he's going to wipe away a graffiti he
was going to do some medical treatment
on people who were who are injured in in
the riots that were happening and then
he got roped into a horrible situation
in which he had to shoot three people
and all of that was on tape the
shootings were on tape and we could see
from the get-go what happened and
barring some sort of extraneous evidence
that showed the contrary and i always
wait on these cases i really do i try to
be considered about jumping in in the
early moments of cases and giving you
sort of preliminary thoughts without all
of the evidence being available because
sometimes you get more evidence that
wasn't available i'd rather be late than
be first and wrong late and write is
better than first and wrong okay but
everybody in the media is incentivized
to give an opinion on cases right from
the get-go and and without any provisos
and so the media in the face of the
available evidence suggested that the
written house went there as a white
supremacist to murder people here's a
supercut from arabian people making the
suggestion beginning with jason johnson
over at msnbc
ridden house is basically what you would
have had in a school shooter he's a 17
year old kid he shouldn't have had a gun
he crossed state lines to supposedly
protect property no he was going out to
shoot people kyle rittenhouse the 17
year old vigilante kyle rittenhouse the
vigilante kyle rittenhouse the armed
teenage vigilante a 17 year old
vigilante
arguably a domestic terrorist picked up
a rifle drove to a different state to
shoot people kyle rittenhouse
a guy who's deeply racist went with
weapons to a black lives matter protest
looking to get in trouble he did he
murdered a couple of people rittenhouse
uh the 17 year old kid
just running around
shooting and killing protesters you see
the 17 year old who was radicalized by
trumpism took his ar-15 to kenosha and
became a killer
okay so i'm kyle rittenhouse is going to
be a very very rich man if the jury does
what it obviously has to do in this case
and acquits him because kyle written how
should have all she should have his
lawyers on speed dial
this makes covington catholic look like
nothing covington catholic was about the
humiliation of a bunch of school kids
for doing nothing but standing there you
have
commentators on these networks with the
tape available calling him a domestic
terrorist and a white supremacist these
are prominent people there's people like
chank wieger and steve schmidt of the
lincoln project which has a habit of
going after minors john heilemann
talking about his domestic terrorist
joe scarborough suggesting that he's
running around shooting and killing
protesters
you're not a protester once you go for
somebody's gun guys that ain't how that
works
and you'll remember that facebook
legitimately banned links to
rittenhouse's defense fund we had his
lawyer on before the before the trial
began
and his legal team was saying they could
not raise funds they couldn't crowdfund
so you could have kamala harris bailing
out rioters in the middle of the 2020
blm riots but kyle rittenhouse could not
raise a defense fund because the big
tech companies essentially labeled him a
domestic terrorist they labeled him
somebody who was not worthy of being
able to raise money for his legal
defense
the blaze reported that just last year
facebook has banned users from sharing a
crowdfunding link to assist with the
legal fees for 17 year old kyle
rittenhouse who was charged with
homicide last week following fatal
shootings that occurred during a ride in
kenosha but the site allows posts asking
for fundraising for several other
individuals who have been charged with
crimes including murder
and like so they basically singled out
written house
the washington times reported online
fundraisers were made for the teen's
legal defense shortly after he was
identified as the suspect but they
quickly vanished from gofundme gofundme
said that campaigns for written house
violated its terms of service but did
not explain any further
facebook did allow links for other
fundraisers including mark wilson a 21
year old who's charged with felony
murder after killing a 17 year old girl
there was a gofundme started by michael
moore to support individuals prosecuted
for tearing down monuments
there's a minnesota freedom fund
promoted by a commonwealth harrison all
of these people are able to raise money
not kyle rittenhouse because cal
rittenhouse was prejudged by the media
to be a domestic terrorist guilty white
supremacist
and none of it ended up being true
none of it
okay this case never should have been
brought again my faith in the system is
such that i figured if they're bringing
a case maybe they know something i don't
because that does happen in trial
sometimes sometimes they bring a case
and then the case ends up being stronger
than you thought it was going to be or
sometimes they bring a case and it ends
up being weaker than you thought it was
going to be and you don't know until the
evidence is in the room
and so i tend to withhold judgment in
these cases until the evidence is in the
room
okay but when you see a case this bad
being brought this horrible being
brought you got to think the institution
has now been gutted from the inside when
prosecutors are bringing cases
specifically because of political
pressure
you cannot feel safe
i'm talking about you you cannot feel
safe in a system where prosecutors are
bringing cases purely out of political
pressure
if you happen to be on the wrong side of
the media in any particular conflict
you will end up in the prosecutor's
crosshairs and it undermines my faith in
the system when it comes to everything
from the blm rioters most of whom were
basically let off scot-free
to the sentencing of people on january
6th again i think criminals should go to
jail if you commit a crime you should go
to jail
but now i want to see all the evidence
in all these cases
because
i gotta say when you again when you see
a little bit of the iceberg above the
water line you start to think oh maybe
these institutions maybe maybe there's
that iceberg is real and i don't want to
rip on the institutions i'm a
conservative i think the institutions
are necessary and good but only if they
follow due process of law
and prosecutorial discretion is part of
due process of law and the prosecutorial
discretion
is supposed to be independent and not
shaped by media pressure
who's got two thumbs and wants you to
like and subscribe